-Welcome back!
-Great to be back.
-It's so happy to have you here.
And this is such a --
this is such a cool show.
This is a show where you talk
about your father.
-Mm-hmm.
-And you tell stories about him.
You also read stories that he
read to you when you were a kid
and then in turn when he
was older, you read to him.
-Exactly.
-So this is
a very personal show,
a very intimate show?
-Yes, but the stories are
fantastic stories, and I begin
reading them, but then I perform
the hell out of them.
[ Laughter ]
-Uh-huh.
-I pretty much do everything
I can possibly do as an actor.
-Well, that's a fantastic way
to spend a couple hours,
but you, again, because this is
more personal, obviously,
you've been on stage
a lot on Broadway.
You're going to have people who
are talking during shows.
-[ Chuckles ] Oh, yes.
You -- and you recently had
an issue where you had to stop
the show?
-Yes, yesterday, your producer
was in the audience.
[ Laughter ]
It wasn't him.
-Thank God. [ Laughs ]
-I walked out to a very nice
entrance applause like that.
As soon as the applause
died down,
I haven't even begun yet,
right in front of me
in the first row center,
there was a fellow talking
just about as loud as we're
talking right now.
-[ Laughs ]
-"I don't want to go
to Sardi's again.
I always go to Sar--"
It was like... [ Stammers ]
And he kept on talking.
I was talking,
and he was talking.
[ Laughter ]
And all I could think was,
"I have two hours to go."
-[ Laughs ] Yeah.
-And I -- all I could do was
say, "is there anything
I can do to help here?"
[ Laughter ]
"Is there a problem?
Because only one of us can talk,
you know."
And the audience was on my side.
-I bet. I would imagine.
[ Laughter ]
I would imagine.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-So anyways, it was pretty...
-No one said,
"let him talk, John!"
-No. [ Laughs ]
-"He's got to figure out a meal
after this!"
-[ Laughs ] That's right.
-You've obviously had
that happen over the years
being on stage a lot.
You have sort of a heroic --
I mean, obviously it was very
heroic for the people
in the audience last night.
-Yeah.
-But you went above
and beyond one time.
-There was -- actually it was
quite a beautiful moment.
I was in this wonderful play,
"M. Butterfly" in the late '80s
in which I played --
I constantly talked directly
to the audience.
I went in and out of scenes.
And there was a scene where
a dance was going on.
I was simply watching it.
And I noticed a woman,
an old woman, again,
in the front row center.
That seems to be the key seat...
-Yeah.
-...in all my stories.
-Say the ushers go, "you look
like -- you look like trouble.
Let me put you in the front."
-Yes, exactly.
[ Laughter ]
She was struggling to her feet
and trying --
She must have been in her 80s.
Trying to make her way
to the aisle.
And as soon as
the dance started,
and I began to talk
to the audience again,
she was still standing there.
I said, "can I help you?
Is there something wrong?"
Once again.
She had to be brought
to the aisle
laying down on her back.
-Oh, my goodness.
-The EMTs came in to take care
of her.
The audience went completely
silent.
Word got to the house manager,
to the stage manager, to me,
that she was all right.
I told the crowd.
They started to applaud.
I said, "quiet down."
[ Laughter ]
It must have taken about
five minutes.
-Oh, wow.
-And they -- she was, indeed,
all right, but, you know,
as years have gone by,
like a dozen people have told me
they were in the audience
that night,
and they'd never seen anything
more theatrical.
[ Laughter ]
-But then is it true that you
also ran into her son? Is it --
-Oh, yes.
I didn't run into him.
I was doing a Q&A
at the Museum of Broadcasting.
TV and Broadcasting
and doing -- answering questions
from the audience.
A gentleman got up, without a
question, but he had a letter.
And he read it out loud.
It was a letter from me
to this old woman.
[ Audience "Aw"s ]
Years before saying,
"I'm so sorry you missed
the rest of the show.
Please come back as my guest
and come have tea with me."
And he told the audience
that I had done this.
-[ Laughs ]
-And I didn't remember.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Yeah, I was like...
All I could say was,
"what a nice guy."
[ Laughter ]